hey guys welcome back to weekly dead
stream recap as always and today was a
little bit of a shorter stream as the
devs did save because there wasn't a lot
of patch notes as there was last week
and no there wasn't a faction war
statement today thank [ __ ] but we don't
care about that we only care about the
notes and I got all of you covered so
let's get started
so first off the new blue content is
some mythic outfits maybe you've already
seen it but I already have a video for
you so I'll play that for you right now
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so those were cool big fan of the new
effects for each of the outfits the
outfit themselves though not a big fan
for the samurais but the effects were
nice though I did like the cool effect
to it those are going to be costing you
$15 and steel each so get those while
you got the chance
next up patch 1.09 which we talked about
in the last dev streamed video last week
that patch will be released next week on
PC and then the week after that for
consoles as said by the devs if you
don't remember that patch had to do with
a nerf decentering and the four v4 modes
and another revenge patch and more if
you miss the video it will be in the
description for you to watching it
caught up regarding the public test
though the devs were reading feedback
from the community and our aware of bugs
such as losing an entire rank when
losing a game and gaining very little
rank when winning and the skill of
players being uneven to make in on the
fair match so that will be fixed before
the next test this isn't exactly a date
for the next public test but they are
still fixing things and hopefully
there'll be one eventually and hopefully
very soon next up there was a Q&A with
Roman and basically to summarize the
first defensive meta out of stamina and
chip damage fix will be in the firt will
be in the next public test whenever that
happens to be so hopefully this will
help against Turtles and make the
tournament more enjoyable I do like how
they're actually going to be adding chip
damage or whenever it really is needed
for some of these hatches and for some
of these characters that continuously
block so hopefully like I said the
public has to be very soon the devs are
also working on getting rid of the
unlock tech and it should be in the next
patch and none of you are aware of the
unlock tech go watched any of splices
videos great guy I'll leave one of these
tournament tournament videos in the
description watch one of it at some high
level play there's a lot of unlock tech
where you were to get out of guard stand
to kind of swing behind you kind of
throw off the player it's not really
supposed to be a thing but it's used in
high-level play to throw up some people
so I'll leave that down in the
description for you to watch they're
still working on getting the zone
flicker bug fixed this bug is been in
the game though I believe since the
start so if they could really hurry that
up that'd be great
although it is one of the key things
Orochi has is that flicker because it
seems to be giving me every [ __ ] time
I would really enjoy it if they
don't have that in the game anyway
they're planning on fixing warlords
dodge recovery next season because he is
the class with the fastest dodge
recovery in the game but he's also a
heavy which doesn't make any sense at
all usually heavy should have the
slowest amount and I believe the
assassin should have the most but
warlords that one person still no word
on the executions everybody's been one
thing for like the past month and a half
so who knows when that's going to come
out Ubisoft is also testing new game
modes but who knows when that will be
out regarding the black screen bug at
the end of the game they have no news on
a fix yet but hopefully soon because
I've experienced this way too many times
when I should have it's really annoying
and then to end the stream they showed a
couple of community creation videos not
that it really was that important some
of them were alright but it was more
just gifts and funny videos and then
that was really the end of the stream so
if it was a bit less or if this video is
a bit short not much was talked about in
the stream but hopefully next week it'll
be a good long stream of a lot of patch
notes a lot of good information because
I believe next week that means patch
1.09 should come out so that should be
some feedback on the whole patch and how
everything's working
but if anyway guys if did like the video
leave like dislike it if you didn't and
if you're new subscribe for more on our
content on this channel and hit that
Bell right next to it to be part of the
notification scott only takes a couple
of seconds and it really does help me
out my most recent videos pop it over
the top right of the screen if you want
to watch that we discussed all season
two has been in for honor and how if it
hurt or did they help the game at all so
I would highly recommend you check that
out but anyway guys thank you all for
watching and I will see you all later if
I guess